hi I'm Jonny I'm Stacey my name is Eric
and today I'm gonna turn my mom email
yes gonna be bad
it means emotional so there is
definitely a lot of that I also put some
red and pink around the eyes to make it
look like I've been crying all night
people thought you were weird you're
just like what's your problem well why
do you think I do my makeup like this
it's hard to put in words but it's just
who you are I don't think she had any
questions about why did my makeup the
way I did all of it started around the
time that like nee was there in your
divorce she really has told me like a
few times that she wants to look like me
so I'm gonna make that happen
I'm Kirby program a very old school you
grew up okay okay so far I think it's
gonna look very bad
so the first thing we're going to be
doing is we're gonna change this and my
son is dressing me this is sort of in my
thought we have some eyeliner here for
your dad or guyliner I need you to like
actually shear but I need you to do to
be honest yeah sure great be like emo
music what I'm heard of a Hawthorne
Heights no taking back sunday no ma
you're moving
of course I'm moving you're sticking
something in my eye fantastic oh shoot
okay my golly one eye is enough Senses
Fail I'm sorry oh this is not looking
how I wanted it look the all-american
rejects no do you mouthing alright so
now we have the eyeshadow so what we're
gonna use is none of these colors we're
just gonna use that solid black no Oh No
why am i doing so bad
is he having extra black everywhere
which is a benefit or a bonus here okay
I made up a lot of email kids have hair
in their eyes I don't think we can
accomplish that today there comes some
prepare we're gonna try to make you look
like an anime character who's now drew
brees this is black no I don't I'm black
look what a lot of emo kids and scene
kids put on a bandana and all the
attention is drawn to your sad eyes do I
need some kind of appropriate fun do I
need like a weapon or anything no I
think I look just horrifying I think I
agree so great
oh wow
not bad actually that's pretty good
thank you
I got the validation of my father my
eyes they just look like I've been
crying
that's very me that's good to know it's
something to do together yeah
where are your dignity for your son I
love it I think it'd be cool if she took
off the makeup it was a good experience
I was happy to hear Stacy explain it
today because of course at the time she
didn't have the ability to express it so
she expressed it in makeup clothes and
here it was possibly the most help
healthy way I could have done things
hurting yourself is not a healthy way
express those you know that angst and
that hurt do you feel more emo now I
feel empowered
you don't feel depressed no it doesn't
get any easier to express your emotions
um you know you can't take yourself too
seriously you have a sudden urge to go
on MySpace
I want to go to Hot Topic go to the
works boy yeah I think you should keep
the makeup on for the rest I think uh my
mom is gonna be thrilled to see you oh
yeah I sure AM and I'm gonna be snapchat
mm and uh I bram know twittering oh yeah
that fake MySpace don't have a MySpace